hi this is Steve with Dabba lab welcome
to the course this is Amazon Alexa
development 101 and I'll be the voice
behind the videos and the guy that you
can ask questions to as you work your
way through the lessons the goal of this
course is to give you an introduction to
building skills for Amazon Alexa and to
do that as quickly as possible but
without moving so fast that you don't
get a solid understanding of what you're
doing this is an introductory level
course so if you have experience
programming that's great but if you've
never written a line of code in your
life that is ok - there is absolutely no
prior experience necessary that said to
make the best use of our time I will
make some assumptions for example I'll
assume that you're familiar with what
Alexa is from a user perspective and
that you have some basic computing
skills the course is broken down into a
collection of short videos all of them
are under 10 minutes but most are around
5 minutes also there are a lot of really
great resources online that complement
this course so I'll mention some of
those as we go and provide links finally
all of my demos will be done on a Mac
but if you're using Windows or Linux you
should be able to follow along just fine
ok that's it for my introduction to kick
things off in the next video we'll talk
about getting started with Alexa
development and how Alexa works from a
high-level technical perspective
so the jumping-off point for getting
started with Alexa development is the
Amazon developer portal and it's located
at developer Emma's on comm and to get
started you'll want to spend some time
browsing through the public pages there
especially the Alexa section of the site
what you'll quickly learn when you do
that is that Alexa is way more than just
the brand and the brains behind the
Amazon echo Alexa is also a service from
Amazon that makes it possible for
anybody to extend Alexis capabilities or
incorporate Alexa into smart devices and
software for developers the Amazon Alexa
service provides the Alexa skills kit
and the Alexa voice service the skills
kit lets you add new capabilities that
make Alexa smarter these are called
skills so if Alexa doesn't do something
now that you'd like you to do you can
teach your how by creating a skill the
Alexa voice service on the other hand is
used for adding Alexa to new devices or
software so for example if you wanted to
create a voice enabled toaster with
Alexa embedded in it you use the Alexa
voice service to do that
our topic in this course is building
skills so we're gonna be taking a closer
look at the Alexa skills kit the Alexa
skills kit is a collection of resources
to make it easier for developers to
create new skills and the skills kit
includes documentation software
development kits application programming
interfaces and example code and we'll be
talking about these in more detail later
in the course using the skills kit is
completely free in fact most of what you
are going to be doing you should
shouldn't have to pay for that's
building publishing and hosting skills
and certainly nothing that we're doing
in this course should cost you anything
at a very high level there are two
things that you're gonna need to do to
create skills you'll need to tell the
Amazon Alexa service about your skill
and you'll need to build a skill service
that provides your skills functionality
the first part is done through the
Amazon developer portal and it doesn't
require any coding but it does require
an understanding of how Alexa works from
a technical perspective and we'll be
covering that building a skill service
is a bit more technical
does require coding however even if
you've never coded anything before in
your life you can build a skill service
using Amazon Web Services pretty easily
and that's what we'll be doing in this
course we'll talk more about skill
services in a minute but first let's
take a closer look at the skill set up
skill configuration settings tell the
Amazon Alexa service about your skill so
Alexa knows how to recognize when users
are requesting your skill and the
functionality that it provides new
skills are set up through the Amazon
developer portal at developer Dynamis on
comm and when you setup a new skill you
define how users enable and interact
with it and how the Alexa service will
communicate with your skill service
that's going to provide the skills
functionality the developer portal is
also where you provide details about
your skill for users and where you
submit your skill to be published for
anybody to use and we'll talk about that
in more detail later on in the course
your skills service provides your skills
functionality and this is the code that
you're gonna write to take action on and
respond to user requests Amazon doesn't
care how you create your skill service
you can use any programming language or
technology stack as long as it can
properly communicate with the Alexa
service that said the easiest and the
recommended way to build skills is by
using Amazon Web Services or AWS and
that's what we'll be doing so to wrap up
let me summarize how Alexa works with
custom skills first a user speaks to an
Amazon echo or an Alexa enabled device
and the audio is streamed from the
device to the Alexa service next the
Alexa service converts the voice stream
to text and determines if the request is
for a skill by looking at skill
configuration information that the
developer set up if the request is for a
skill the Alexa service sends the
request to a skill service that's set up
to provide the skills functionality and
the skill service takes action on the
request and generates a response that's
sent back to Amazon Alexa through the
Alexa skills kit ap
from there the Alexis service responds
back to the user and the process is
complete okay so that is it for our
high-level technical overview in the
next video we'll set up a skill in the
Amazon developer portal
so in the last lesson you've learned
that there are two things that you need
to do as a developer to create a new
skill you need to set up your skill in
the Amazon developer portal and then you
need to build a skill service to provide
your skills functionality in this lesson
we're gonna set up our skill in the
developer portal the bare minimum
requirements and to do that you're gonna
need to have an Amazon developer account
and you can get that by going over to
developer amazon.com if you're not
already there and signing up I'm not
gonna walk through the signup process
because it's pretty straightforward the
one point that I do want to make however
is that when you're signing up if you're
creating a developer account you want to
use the email address that you use with
your primary Amazon account so if you've
got an Amazon Prime account or an
account that you've used for your echo
if you have an echo which incidentally
another point I don't think I made is
that you don't need to have an echo to
do development and I'll get into that a
little bit later but point here is that
you want to use the email address that
you use with your primary Amazon account
it will make testing a whole lot easier
when you sign up if you don't have an
Amazon account of course you can create
one as you go through the the signup
process and there's no charge to create
a developer account that's that's free
and once you've created your account you
can go ahead and log in and when you log
in you'll be at the developer Council
and the dashboard is where it drops you
by default and from here what you want
to do is you want to go over to the
Alexa menu and then under the Alexa menu
you've got two options the skills kit
and the voice service we talked about
what those were in an earlier lesson and
we're dealing with skills so we're gonna
get started with the skills kit and when
you come in here if you haven't created
skills yet you're gonna see what I'm
looking at right now which is just a
blank list there's no skills created at
this point and we're going to add a new
skill by clicking the add new skill
button here
and we're just setting up the bare
basics for our skill and so there's a
number of pieces of information that
we're gonna provide there's no coding in
here so everything that we're gonna do
in the developer portal is really going
to be configuration information so no
coding here we're gonna do that in a
little bit but there was quite a few
pieces of information that we need to
provide it looks intimidating when you
first kind of start poking through this
but it's actually not too bad the skill
information is where it all starts
you can leave most of the defaults so
we're gonna stick with the custom
interaction model and this is gonna
provide us with the most flexibility
when we're creating skills there are
different skill types we're not going to
cover these other skill types in this
course but if you're curious about what
they are you can learn more by clicking
this link the language is we're gonna
also in this case in my case I'm going
to use US English and that's my default
but Alexis supports us English UK
English and German and actually when you
create a skill you can create the skill
to support multiple languages that's
also outside what we're gonna cover in
this course so I'm gonna leave the deep
voltage u.s. English the default we're
also going to leave down here under the
global global field so the audio player
video app in render templates we're not
going to be covering those in this
course so you can leave those all as no
what we do need however is our skill
name in the invocation name and we're
gonna use hello world for both the skill
name and the invocation name and the
skill name is the name that users are
going to use to find our skill both in
the Alexa companion app that's on your
iPhone or your Android phone and then
also they're gonna use that to enable
the skill so if you're familiar with how
Alexa works you enable skills by saying
Alexa an able skill name and then you
work with skills or you
invoke the functionality of skills by
using the invocation name so after I had
enabled my skill I would say Alexa asked
hello world something or Alexa tell
hello world something as an example and
then my skill would understand the users
intent which we're gonna get into in the
next video based on what they say and
then provide or act on the users request
at that point and so right now we just
need hello world for our name and hello
world for our invocation name and we'll
be all set we can use just about
anything while we're developing for the
skill name in the invocation name but
when you get ready to publish your skill
there are guidelines for the invocation
name that you need to follow so that
your invocation name doesn't collide
with or conflict with existing skill
functionality or Alexa native
functionality and so you want to review
those guidelines when you get ready to
publish your skill we're gonna cover
that later we'll get into that but if
you're curious you can certainly click
on the link here to read more about that
but at this point all we need to do is
click Save and we have created the bare
minimum for settings that are required
to to get our skill going we'll need to
finish up the configuration with our
interaction model we'll need to tell our
skill how to pass information and get
information back from our skill service
which we do under the configuration
settings and then there's an area to
test our skill and then we submit our
skill for publishing here and there's
some privacy and compliance information
that we need to provide on this last
section here it looks like a lot we're
gonna walk through all of it it's
actually not too bad but for right now
that is where we're gonna leave it and
then in the next lesson we're gonna talk
more about the interaction model and get
into intense and slots
in the last lesson we set up our hello
world skill in the developer portal with
the bare minimum setting so in this
lesson we're going to pick up where we
left off and we're gonna set up an
interaction model for our skill an
interaction model let's the Amazon Alexa
service know how users are going to
interact with our skill the interaction
model is essentially configuration
information that's provided in a
structured format that the Alexa service
can understand and to get a bit more
technical the interaction model is
structured as JSON or JavaScript object
notation and if you're familiar with
Jason that's great but if not no worries
because there is a tool that you can use
to create an interaction model and you
don't need to know anything about Jason
to use it and this is new it is still in
beta but it's pretty nice and we're
gonna use it to create our interaction
model here so we'll just go in and
launch the skill builder so interaction
models can get pretty complex depending
on what your skill does but the two most
important things that you need to know
about our intense and slots and intense
represent the actions your skill can
perform based on what users say and by
defining intense and what users might
say that's associated with those intents
that lets the Alexa service know how to
process the what the user saying and
what users want and how to pass that on
to our skill service so that the skill
service can respond intense might also
have arguments and those are called
slots so slots are used to extract
specific pieces of information from what
users say for example if you wanted a
skill that was able to address a user by
name our skill might prompt the user by
saying what's your name to that the user
might respond by saying my name is Steve
so to get the value Steve from a user's
response we'd use a slot and we'll take
a look at slots in more detail and all
later video but for now we're just going
to set up a simple intent named general
greeting that our skill can respond to
when a user says hello and to do that we
go in over here and we're gonna add an
intent and there are two types of
intents there's custom intents and
built-in intents for right now we're
just going to set up a custom intent and
again the name of that intent is going
to be general greeting spell that right
like that and we'll create that intent
and the our skill is going to respond
when a user says hello so that is going
to when a user says hello that's going
to tell our skill to act on the general
greeting and that is what we're going to
end with for now so we'll save our model
and then we'll build our model which
will take a minute okay that is it for
this lesson we have our skill set up
with a basic interaction model and now
it's time to start building our skill
service and we're gonna dive into that
in our next lesson
so at this point we have our skill set
up and we have a basic interaction model
that has one custom intent named general
greedy and that intent handles a case
where a user says hello now we need a
skill service to actually do something
with an intent request and since skills
extend Alexis capability and can be
created by anybody the logic for a skill
lives outside of the Amazon Alexa
service so we need to build and host our
skill service and then tell Alexa where
that service is located and we do that
in the configuration section of the
Alexa skill here I mentioned earlier
that Amazon doesn't really care where
your skill exists or how it was created
in terms of like the programming
language or the technology stack just so
long as it can communicate with the
Alexa service but the easiest and
recommended way to create and host a
skill services by using lambda functions
through Amazon Web Services or AWS and
that's what we're gonna do so you're
gonna select the AWS lambda a RN option
here and then we're gonna need in a RN
which is an Amazon resource name which
is the identifier for the lambda
function so to get that and to set up
the lambda function you need to head
over to aws.amazon.com and create an
account there if you don't have one
already make sure that you use the same
email address that you used when you
created your account on the Amazon
developer portal the sign up process is
straight forward so I'm not going to
walk through that the one point I will
make calendar is that in the AWS signup
process you will get prompted for a
credit card I mentioned earlier that
nothing that we're doing in this course
is gonna cost anything because AWS
provides a free tier and you can see
that here the first million requests per
month are free so as long as you don't
go over that we are good but if you want
to learn more about the pricing just go
to aws.amazon.com slash pricing and you
can see how
the pricing works after you've created
your account go ahead and log into the
management console and I'm logged in
right now once you log in you want to go
to the services menu up here and then
you want to under the compute section
you want to go to lamda here okay and
before I create a lambda function I just
want to talk for a minute about what
this is so lambda functions are referred
to as serverless functions so it's a
platform that allows you to create
services software services without
having to worry about setting up and
creating the server which is where that
server list name comes from of course
there are servers behind it but we don't
have to think about any of that stuff we
can just jump right in in write our code
and it's a really nice and easy way to
to do it because just a lot of the a lot
of the complexity is not something that
you have to worry about in terms of the
the hosting and the infrastructure so we
just jump in and start working in the
code so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna create a function and Amazon
provides some templates they call them
blueprints that you can use as a
starting point and lambda can be used
for lots of different things not just
creating Alexa skills but if you search
for Alexa Alex Alexa that works you'll
see some of the the blueprints that are
provided we're going to use one of these
blueprints to get started but I'm not
going to talk through what the the
blueprint is doing the reason that we're
gonna pick one of the Alexa blueprints
is because the Alexa skills kit has an
SDK or a software development kit that
makes it easier to communicate back and
forth with the Alexa service we're gonna
be coding our skill and node and when
you use the blueprint the Alexa SDK is
included with it so just select any one
of the no
jas SDKs and I'm going to choose this
Alexa skills kit sdk for fax skill the
next screen what we're gonna do is we're
going to set it up so that it is
triggered when request comes in from the
Alexa skills kit so we do that by
selecting Alexa skills kit here and then
we move on it we give our function a
name so I'm gonna call this hello world
Alexa skill line like that and I'm gonna
get rid of the description here you
don't have to do that but and then you
can see the the template code here
that's provided again I'm not going to
get into this right now we will come
back and talk about that a little bit
but this is a skill service for a space
fax skill so the only other thing that
you need to do to get the the skill
service code set up is select a an
execution role and this is what gives
the lambda function permission to run
and if you're just getting set up and
you have not done this before you're
gonna wanna select from here create a
custom role and when you do that a
window will pop up that will walk you
through the process it'll create a roll
named lambda underscore basic execution
by default you don't need to change any
here thing here you just choose allow
and then that'll pop you back over here
and that roll will be selected and
that's all you need to do for for this
example you need to choose next and then
create function
and that is it so we have our we have
our skill service set up as a lambda
function now the only thing left to do
is to let the skill in the developer
council know the a RN or the Amazon
resource name which is this up here so
we just want to copy that and then go
back to the Alexa developer or the
Amazon developer portal and to our Alexa
configuration and then we want to go
ahead and paste in that air and and so
when we do that and click Save now we
have our settings connected to our back
end skill service and we can test that
real quick and this is where we're gonna
end up or this is where we're gonna end
this lesson but we'll come back and
we'll talk about testing in more detail
well test it by just saying open hello
world and we should get a response back
and we did so this is the request that
the Alexa service sent to our skill
service and our skill service got that
our skill service again our lambda
function got that and generated this
response and you can see it's a response
that is having to do with space backs
and you can listen to it here if you
want to hear here's your fact a year on
Mercury is just 88 days long okay so now
we we have at this point a functioning
custom skill we're gonna go talk about
what's going on here and modify it in
the next lesson
so now that we have a fully functional
skill let's take a closer look at what's
going on in the code for the skill
service that we set up in the last
lesson so head over to aws.amazon.com
and login to the management council if
you're not already logged in and then
from there go to the lambda section of
the management council and again you can
get there by going to the services menu
and then to lamda and now in your
function list you should see the
function that we created in the last
lesson the hello world elects a skill
and you want to go into that and we're
gonna talk about the code here that was
provided as part of the blueprint that
we selected so the blueprint that we
selected was for a skill that provides
space backs and if you wanted a space
fact skill we are done it at this point
aside from maybe adding some additional
facts or changing these ones for that
matter if you wanted a fact skill for
any topic you could go in here and just
change these facts and you'd be done
we're gonna we're gonna move beyond that
and we're not gonna talk a whole lot
about what this this blueprint provides
and in fact we we don't need any of that
stuff so we're gonna ignore that for
right now the what I do want to do
however is I want to talk about what's
going on in here at a higher level and
then talk about how we can make some
changes that will allow functionality
that we are going to define ourselves
more specifically how to deal with the
general greeting intent that we defined
as part of our interaction model we're
gonna do that here but first of all all
of this code is written in JavaScript
and it is run in the context of node.js
and so no js' is an environment that
allows javascript to be run on the
server and this lambda function is using
nodejs
to allow us to execute this code in here
which is JavaScript so you don't need to
know JavaScript or node.js for this
course but if you wanted a a really deep
understanding of what's going on in here
that would
require an understanding of both
JavaScript and node but what I will tell
you is that the Alexa skills kit makes
doing a lot of this very very simple so
if you are not a coder or are not
familiar with JavaScript you don't need
to be intimidated there might look like
there's a lot going on here but actually
it's it's pretty straightforward and
it's pretty simple and that is because
of this right here the Alexus skills kit
provides an SDK which is a wrapper for
the API that makes sending and receiving
the messages back and forth between your
skills service and the alexa service
really straightforward and so let me
show you how that works so the the first
thing I want to point out is what this
skill is doing by default or this skill
service and then how we're going to
change that up so if we go into our
service simulator and we looked at that
real quickly last lesson and we just say
open HelloWorld we're gonna see now that
the skill service responds with a space
fact because that's how its set up right
now and we can see that if we go back
over here the launch request is the
intent that is gonna get called when the
skill is opened without any utterances
that are associated with another intent
and so when you just say open skill or
open HelloWorld in this case this launch
request is is what is going to pick up
so in this case this launch request is
calling this get fact function down here
and that's what's replying with our
space fact and we're going to change
that to do something different and we've
got some functionality that's provided
as part of the SDK that makes that
really easy this ask and tell down here
allow us to prompt the user for a
response or to just speak back a
statement and we're gonna prompt them by
using this ask option up here
so we'll go like this and then we're
gonna what are we gonna ask them we're
gonna say welcome can you say hello and
then we are if they don't respond we're
gonna re prompt so after five seconds if
they don't say anything we're gonna ask
them again can you say hello okay so now
when we save this and the user just
opens the skill our skill should respond
now with this welcome can you say hello
and then can you say hello and let's see
we'll test so open hello world and there
we get our new response welcome can you
say hello okay but when the user
responds with hello well with hello our
service responds with an error and the
reason that it's responding with an
error is because right now the skill
service doesn't know how to deal with
that intent so the intent let's take a
look here so over here the Alexa service
sent this request over and this is the
the Jason the the structured information
that the service Alexa service is
sending to our skills service and it's
asking the skill service or telling this
skill service that the user is looking
for this general greeting intent here
but we don't have code in our skill
service that understands what to do with
that and so we need to change that up to
make it work and the names here map to
intents that we've defined in our
interaction model or should and so we
don't have this get new intent in our
interaction model so we'll just change
this up to be general greeting
like that and we're gonna say we're
gonna respond back with tell and then
[Music]
nice to meet you
okay so now will we save this now what
should happen is we should when we
opened the skill Alexa will prompt us
prompt the user to say can you say hello
when the user says hello Alexis going to
respond with nice to meet you so let's
give that a try so we will do open again
and don't have to test it again but
welcome can you say hello you will and
now we say hello nice to meet you
okay so there it is that is wiring up
our intents that are defined in the
interaction model with the code in the
skill service so that the skill service
can prompt and respond in the next
lesson we're going to go a little bit
deeper but we're gonna start by talking
more about testing and then we'll move
on from there
[Music]
so up to this point we've been doing all
of our testing using the service
simulator in the developer portal but
now we're going to take a look at a few
other options when it comes to testing
during the development process the
service simulator is usually the first
place that you're going to start but
you'll also want to test your skills
using voice interactions so you'll
either need an Amazon echo or some other
Alexa labelled device or software to do
that and you don't need to go buy an
echo but if you have one and it's
configured with the same email address
as your developer portal account you can
start using your echo for testing
without doing anything else and that is
because when you're developing skills
your skills are automatically enabled
for your account and you can see that
using your Alexa companion app or I'm
logged in here at if you go to Alexa
Dynamis on comm and log in and then go
to skills and then your skills you'll
see that your hello world skill is
enabled so you can just say Alexa open
hello world and your hello world skill
will respond if you're using an echo you
can also test with any other Alexa
enabled device or software so if you
don't have an echo there are a growing
number of options to choose from but
here's a few suggestions my first
suggestion is to get the Amazon shopping
app and this is Alexa enabled and
available for both iOS and Android and
so once you install the app there's a
little microphone icon that you can tap
and then you can talk to Alexa just as
though you were using an echo and this
is a great option for for developing the
next is an app called reverb and reverb
is also available for iOS and Android
and it is also got a native app for the
Mac so if you're using the Mac you can
install reverb and I've got it installed
and with Reaper installed you can click
and hold and say Alexa open hello world
welcome can you say hello hello nice to
meet you
and so that is reverb
is a great option again if you don't
have an echo but the the clicking in
holding is maybe not not not ideal but
works well the last option is called
echo sim dot IO and if you don't have an
iOS device or an Android device or a
Macintosh you can install echo sim or
actually you don't need to install it
it's just browser-based and all you need
for echo sim is a computer with a
browser and a microphone so if you don't
have any other options this is available
for you and it works like the reverb app
you click and hold and you can talk to
Alexa the last thing that I want to talk
about is testing the lambda functions in
the abbs management portal so this is a
topic that is a bit more technical and
something that I'll cover in more detail
in a more advanced course but I wanted
to show you real quickly how this works
and so when you have lambda functions
and you want to start testing them you
there's a test tool that's built in to
AWS for a lambda and what what you're
going to need to do to test this tool is
configure it with the Jason message
that's going to be sent to the function
to get a response back and so if you
don't have the the write request here
you will just get an error because the
the lambda function isn't getting the
the message format that it's expecting
but it's it's really easy to get the
right message format if you go into your
test service simulator over here when
you're doing testing here this service
request is the format that you need so
if you copy that and go back over to the
lambda function here and configure and
test and just paste that
if you save and test now you will see a
successful response so just like being
in the the service simulator and again
this is a more advanced topic but
sometimes when you're testing in the
service simulator if your lambda
function is generating an error all
you'll see is that there's an error over
here and you don't get any details about
what might be causing that error if you
take the service request from over here
into the the test test council within
AWS and run the test you'll get a lot
more details about what might be going
on and why your lambda function is
erroring out over here and again more a
little more technical but wanted to show
you that so now you have a few more
options for testing while you're in your
development process and next we'll
discuss skill design and planning
as you spend more time creating skills
you'll quickly realize that there is a
lot more to it than just coding in fact
you may even spend more time planning
and designing your skill than you do
actually building it in the topic of
skill design and planning is one that we
could easily dedicate an entire course
to maybe even a few courses so in this
lesson we're just gonna scratch the
surface and talk through the skill that
will be building in the next lesson
mostly okay so when you're planning a
skill the first step is to come up with
a concept and for this course we're
gonna be building a skill that gives
users recommendations or suggestions for
something and it can be whatever
interests you so for example it could be
recommendations for scary movies to see
or places to visit or foods to try again
whatever you're interested in
I like craft beer so for my example I'm
gonna use a skill that I created called
suggests a beer and after you've come up
with your general concept the next step
is to do a little research to see if
there are any existing skills that are
similar and to do that you can go to
alexa.com and log in and once you've
logged in you go to skills and then just
search for your some keywords that would
be related to your concept and in my
case I just searched for beer and
quickly realize that there are quite a
few beer related skills and so I started
browsing through those skills and
enabling some of them especially the
ones that sounded similar to my original
concept and originally suggested beer
was just going to be a simple sell the
skill that would suggest a random beer
so you would just ask Alexa to suggest a
beer and you would get a beer suggestion
back and what I realized is that there
was a handful you know three or four I
think other skills that did exactly that
and so that's not uncommon there's a lot
of skills in the skills store and so if
you if you run into that with your
concept you just want to think about how
your skill could be different and
hopefully a little bit better so what I
did is I enabled the skills that were
closest to the the suggestion concept
that I had and I realized that none of
those
skills allowed users to get beer
suggestions for local craft beers and so
I thought I'd be cool if somebody could
suggest a beer
based on their state or suggested beer
based on a style which is something else
that I didn't see in any of the existing
skills so the concept was still the same
it's a skill for suggestion suggesting
beers but the the difference was that I
was gonna build a skill that would allow
users to get mere suggestions for local
craft beers and again so if you if you
search your concept and you see that
there's other skills that are doing
something similar don't get discouraged
just spend some time looking at those
skills and figure out how you can make
your skill a little bit different and
embed it okay so once you have locked in
your general skill concept the next
thing you want to do is start sketching
out some sample dialogues and mapping
out your your skill and I just do that
in a in a Google Doc and there is a lot
more work in planning and design then
you tend to think there is when you
first get into it but I start with a
name for the the skill and for the beer
suggestions example I that was the name
that I came up with beer suggestions but
as I was thinking about the user
actually interacting in the possible
invocation requests I realized that the
way that I wanted it to work the beer
suggestions name wasn't the right name
for the invocation name so I used
suggestive beer as the invocation name
and the reason that I did that is
because I really wanted this first and
so in the Alexa environment you can say
Alexa and then just reference the
invocation name and so I made the
invocation name sound like an utterance
so it's Alexa suggestive beer is the
first possible invocation request
example and that's really what I was
most interested in and why I used that
as the invocation name
rather than beer suggestions so if I had
used beer suggestions the invocation
would have been something more like
Alexa asked beer suggestions to suggest
a beer and I was just trying to shorten
it to simplify it after you've bought
through some possible invocation
requests examples and as you're thinking
through these it doesn't necessarily
mean that out of the gate you want to
support all of these but you do want to
spend some time thinking through the the
different possible ways that a user will
begin to interact with the skill and
after you've done that you want to
sketch out a couple of the simplest
dialogues so in the shortest case what
is the dialogue look like and for the
suggest a beer example a user would say
Alexis suggests a beer and then Alexa
would say okay do you prefer lagers or
ales the style and then the user would
respond lager in this example and then
Alexa would provide the suggestion in
this case I'd suggest a motive works
between Vienna lager I hope you enjoy it
in the second dialogue I've added the
the ability to filter or select by state
and so the user would start the
interaction with the skill by saying
Alexa suggested beer from Florida or
whatever state and then Alexa would say
okay what style beer do you like and the
user would respond lager and then Alexa
would respond with suggestion in this
case I'd suggest a v-twin Vienna lager
from Motor Works brewing in Bradenton
Florida so I'm really just providing the
brewer and the the location back in this
case so these are two really simple
dialogues when you start thinking about
this I mean there can be lots and lots
of them so start out simple and then
start thinking about after you've
thought through the dialogues and also
when you when you do the dialogues and
sketch them out after you've thought
through them and sketch them out
yourself test them out with friends or
family and you can do a little
role-playing you can pretend to be Alexa
ask your friend or family member to
pretend to be the user tell them what
the skill is gonna do but don't show
them the dialogues just see what they
and that will go a long way to helping
you refine your your dialogues and make
sure that your you're on the right track
in terms of how the interactions might
go after you've gone through that
exercise you can start or what I like to
do is bullet point the key features and
then prioritize them into like key
features which are the features that I
want to make available as soon as
possible and likely as soon as I
published the skill for the very first
time and then secondary features are
kind of backlog features that I might
someday want to add as I as I get time
so the primary features in this case are
features that I selected because they
weren't available in other skills that
were similar so that's why they were my
primary features and then from there I
start mapping out the intents that will
be included in the skill and I am just
focused on the custom intents here and
in this skill it's a simple skill so
we're just gonna have one intent make a
suggestion and then we want to think
about the slot values that are going to
be required to make that suggestion and
so in the case of my suggestive beer
skill I wanted the state and the style
in this case of your skill you might
choose different slots that that you
need to let the user filter for your
suggestion the utterances are the last
thing that I think about and this list
can get very very long so as you start
thinking through all of the different
ways that a user could make requests or
statements or ask questions or provide
information to your skill which are all
referred to as utterances like we talked
about earlier there are lots and lots of
different variations so start out with
some simple ones and then start building
your list out and with the suggested
beer skill this list got well over 50
you very very fast so that list will
grow quickly but the more utterances
that you provide the smarter your skill
is going to be in the better the user
experience is going to be so it's worth
spending the time to to do that okay
Oh like I mentioned in the beginning of
this lesson there's a lot to know when
it comes to planning and designing
skills and we've covered some of the
basics but you'll also want to check out
the Alexa voice design guide and you'll
also want to read through the developer
documentation about understanding how
users invoke custom skills and I've
included links to both of those
resources in the course notes ok now we
are ready to start building our skill
and we'll get started on that in the
next lesson
ok so now it's time to take everything
that we've learned so far and pull it
all together to create a complete skill
end to end and we're gonna be creating
the skill that we talked about the last
lesson the suggestion or recommendation
skill and I'm going to use the local
craft beer example and it's going to be
a skill that lets users get a local
craft beer suggestion for a beer brewed
in a given state we'll start by creating
our skill or setting it up in the
developer portal and then we'll head
over to AWS and we will create our land
of function I have included a link to
the code that I'm gonna be using for
this lesson I put it in github so you
can use that as a a reference so let's
go into the developer console first and
add our new skill here and I'm going to
call this one beer suggestions and I'm
gonna use beer suggestions also for the
invocation aid and for the interaction
model this time rather than using the
skill builder beta we're just going to
add an intent schema and some sample
utterances and I have those that you can
use as a starting point on github and so
I'm going to take that and add my intent
schema here there's just one custom
intent in this intent schema called make
suggestion and a slot for this example
which is the state slot to hold the
state that we're gonna get the beer
suggestion for and then we've got some
built-in intents that are required for
the cancel intent the help intend to
stop intent we also need some utterances
and we are gonna use some examples here
and build from those or you would want
to build from those as you build out a
complete skill so I'm just going to
include three so the user can suggest a
beer from state or say Alexa asked beer
suggestions to suggest a beer from state
and
couple of different variations of that
so go next and while that's building we
will head over to the AWS management
council and we'll add our lambda
function so we'll go create a function
here we're gonna select the skills kit
for node again but we're not using any
of that code this time so it will
include the boilerplate code that comes
with the blueprint but we're gonna get
rid of all of this but first we're gonna
give it a name so I'll say we'll call it
beer the suggestions calexis skills okay
we'll get rid of that and down here
we're gonna start with a just a
bare-bones hello world skill here all
this skill service does is and you can
type that in for practice but all this
does here is includes some handlers for
built-in intents to help cancel and stop
intent and then an unhandled intent
handler here so if the skill doesn't
know what to do with the request that
comes in this is going to respond and
then the launch request just right now
responds so when you go alexxa open in
our case beer suggestions it's just
right now gonna say hello world so it's
not doing a whole lot there we're gonna
build from that and then we just select
the execution rule and we say next and
then create function and now we have our
a our n here so we've got our lambda
function and the a our n is going to be
used back over here in the developer
console as our endpoint so I'm gonna
paste that in just like that and now I
just need to test to make sure that
everything is working up to this point
so I'll say open beer suggestion fat see
if we get a response back and we do and
as you can see it's just saying hello
world now so not doing a whole lot so
what we're gonna do at this point is
we're gonna go back over here and we're
gonna go to our code and we're going to
change it up so that users can ask for a
beer suggestion by state and you can
expand this here which makes it easier
in a future course we're also gonna take
a look at some different code editors
that you would maybe use in your local
environment so if you use Mac or Windows
and if you're making a more involved
skill you'll definitely want to use a
code editor this is great for just
getting started and doing simple skills
in the browser but not probably ideal
for anything beyond something that's
pretty simple like what we're doing okay
so let's go back over here I've got the
the code that we're gonna use for from
my example here you'll want to modify
this if you're picking a different topic
but it's gonna work for the most part
the same way so we're gonna start with
this here which is the data that's gonna
hold our suggestions and so in this case
here this is a a JavaScript object and
it's providing in my case just three
three objects within the object so that
so this is actually a an array of
objects and there's three objects in
here you can kind of think of this like
an Excel spreadsheet each one of these
would be rows and then for each one of
the rows we've got two different cells
with values so we've got state or
columns and suggestion and then a value
for each one so what we're gonna need to
do is we're gonna need to when the user
requests a suggestion for for example
Florida here we're going to need to loop
through these fine Florida and then
back to suggestion oh I see a typo here
- so this is supposed to be Georgia that
okay so the next thing that we're gonna
do is we're going to provide the code
that is going to do the looping and
searching for the response and this is
outside of what we've talked about up to
this point but I want to show you what's
going on anyhow so that now this is just
a little code snippet that I wrote in
JavaScript that we're using in here and
I'll tell you what it's doing so this is
a JavaScript function that's gonna loop
through this data and find the the value
for whatever is passed in as the
property name and the value here so the
property name in this case we're gonna
use state and then the value is going to
be whatever the user has asked for and
that gets passed over as the value of
the state slot from the Alexus service
okay so next so I've got my data and
I've got a way to search through my data
here so now I want to go in here and I
want to add a handler to do that
searching so I'm gonna go over here and
I've got just one handler function for
my one custom intent which is my make
suggestion intent so I'm gonna grab that
and I'll tell you what is going on here
also
okay so we're setting the state slot
variable value to the value that comes
over with the request for the state so
the Alexus services making the request
and within that request the slot state
value is what we're setting to the value
of this variable that we're creating
here and now down here we want to
respond back with the data suggestion or
the suggestion from our data up here so
that's where we use our get suit
function that we created earlier here so
we're responding back calling this
function get suggestion passing in our
data which is all of this here that we
call skill data and setting the property
name which is state and the value that
that function needs we are taking from
here that's being set to what the Alexa
service passed over and then I am
setting that to uppercase to ensure that
it matches my data here and then when it
finds that it will reply back or provide
back the object with the information
that we need with the suggestion and so
I pull the suggestion from that object
to write back or to to respond back to
the user okay the only other thing that
needs to happen here is we just need to
change up the launch request so that
when the user opens the skill we're
telling them what to do and so I've got
this here and I'll grab this let's see
and we are gonna paste that in so now
when the skills open Alexa says I can
suggest a beer from any state in the
United States what state would you like
a beer suggestion for and then the reap
romp asks them to to give a state if
they don't respond within a few seconds
okay at this point we have everything
that we need for the skills service and
I'm going to go ahead and save that and
if you're creating a skill using a
different topic which you probably are
you can change up the slot name here you
could also if you want to expand it a
little bit you could add some additional
values and use those in your response as
well down here but at this point
I've got my skill service built out now
I just want to go test it so I'll go
back over to the developer council here
and go into the service simulator and
start by opening beer suggestions again
to make sure that that is working and
now I just want to try like one of my
utterance is and I'll say from Florida
and that is working so my suggestion for
Florida and if I go back over here just
to verify yes that's what it's supposed
to be responding with of course when I
finish this up I want at all 50 states
and I'll want to add a real suggestion
for each one of the states whatever beer
I want to respond back with I don't
think I've had a beer from all 50 states
but that's maybe something I can put on
my to-do list okay so let me just test
with one other state test with Alabama
and ok is working so at this point I've
got my skill and Ed's setup I've got my
interaction model I've got my skill
service I'm testing it everything seems
to be working and now we are ready to
polish it finish it and then submit it
for certification so we'll talk about
that in the next lesson
so after you have finished coding up
your skill you want to test it and
retest it and test again testing is is
super important we talked about it in an
earlier different ways of testing in an
earlier lesson and you really want to
spend time going through and considering
different utterances and testing those
utterances and in polishing the the
skill and once you've gotten to the
point where you feel pretty good about
it you've tested it in all the different
ways that you think a user might use it
and all of the utterances that you've
provided then you want to start getting
your skill ready to go through the
certification process so that you can
get it out there and make it public and
available for everybody else to use and
that's what we're going to talk about in
this lesson if you go to the the the
test tab for your skill or the test
section there is a link all the way at
the bottom see certification
requirements in our technical
documentation you'll want to read
through this we'll talk through some of
this stuff but you want to be familiar
with the certification process and the
requirements especially the guidelines
around the invocation name you'll want
to take a look at the invocation name
guidelines and just make sure that
you've dotted all your eyes and crossed
all your t's before you submit for the
certification process but once you've
done that you've fully tested it
yourself then you would go to the
publishing information here and complete
the required information here which is
pretty straightforward so you're gonna
pick a category that your skill will be
classified in and for the beer
suggestion example I'm gonna use food
and drink and wine and beverage and then
testing instructions I'm gonna just say
no no special
it's just there's nothing special about
the the testing here but you it does
require you to provide something so I'm
gonna add that in there
let the skill I'm gonna let it be
available for any country even though it
only gives suggestions for states in the
United States right now maybe somebody's
traveling and wants to try a local beer
then you would provide a description
description for the skill find ear by
state and you probably really want to
come up with something a little bit
better for your skill and for the skill
description something that's gonna get
people excited about wanting to try your
skill but just to walk through this I'm
gonna go with something simple and then
you want to provide some example phrases
and this is going to let users know how
they're going to use your skills so it
might say Alexa asked your suggestions
to suggest a ear from Florida maybe
we'll say Alexa open ear suggestions and
suggest a beer something like that so
you want to fill these out in ways that
would show your user how to use your
skill and then provide some key words
down here these are optional but I'll do
beer craft brewing something like that
and then you want to provide some some
icons so these that they do need to be
the the right size so 108 by 108 pixels
for the small icon in 512 by 512 for the
larger icon and I've got
some creative data use here so this is
my small icon and my large icon here
okay and from here you need to go on and
answer some questions about privacy and
compliance so does the skill allow users
to make purchases or spend money and in
my case no does it collect personal
information no does it target children
under 13 no and then you'll want to read
the export compliance and agree to that
and then last does it contain any
advertising and no and then this down
here you do need to provide a privacy
URL and a Terms of Use URL so I've got
those on my site and they do check these
so they're at least they make sure that
there's something there so you do need
to provide this and I've got the other
one is called terms and then once you
have this you can hit save and at this
point we're ready for certifications so
I could just click submit for
certification and this would go through
the certification at this point there's
also an option before you certify to
test your skill with other users beta
users so if you want to do that you
would provide email addresses for the
users that that you want to test and
then it would send out and in from like
a link for them to try it and if they
approve that they would be able to test
your skill that way before you certified
it so that's that's an option the
certification process the experiences
that I've had it's you know a day or two
it's pretty quick and if you if it
doesn't get approved for whatever reason
the response back is is very clear on
what you'll need to do to fix it and
once you fix whatever the issue is and
resubmit it the the process goes goes
pretty quickly it's still you know the
last time I had one that wasn't approved
it was I think it's just a few hours
later after I fixed it and they read it
so goes pretty pretty quickly but at
this point you have a complete skill
that's ready to go and ready to ready to
be certified and from there it will be
live for anybody to use it so that is
our last lesson we will review in the
next lesson and talk about some next
steps from there
so congratulations you've completed the
course you should now have a solid
introductory level understanding of how
to build custom Alexa skills and
hopefully you should be really close to
having your first skill published from
here you'll want to practice what you've
learned thus far and then move on to
some more advanced topics here are some
suggestions for possible next steps
first subscribe to the dabble a channel
on YouTube I published a new video there
every Friday and most of those will be
related next
get a code editor coding in the browser
like we did for this course is fine for
getting started but not for developing
more advanced skills I use an open
source editor called Adam I like it a
lot
it works on Mac Linux or Windows and
best of all it is free consider taking a
javascript course if you want to build
more advanced alexis skills at least
with nodejs most of what you'll need to
know is JavaScript we talked about
JavaScript a very high level but you'll
want to dive deeper there for sure
you'll also want to learn more about
nodejs
learning node mostly involves learning
JavaScript but understanding how node
works and how to use node modules can
make your life as a coder much much
easier the node module you'll want to be
most familiar with at least for Alexa
development is the Alexa skills kit sdk
for node you can learn more about that
by going to github.com slash Alexa and
while you're there dig into the sample
code in the Alexa cookbook well that's
it I really hope you enjoyed the course
and I also hope that if there is
anything that you think I can do to make
it better that you will let me know and
if you have any questions about anything
that we've covered please don't hesitate
to leave a comment and I'll respond just
as quickly as possible thanks again for
taking the course I hope to see you in a
future course